Okay.
The one to offer a few thoughts about how to think about some of these legal
developments that you're studying
and particularly the McCleskey decision.
The class ski really stands out in American jurisprudence has one of those
tremendous contradictions.
We survived this era of segregation and racial oppression and racial hierarchy.
Now that was dismantled during the 1950s and sixties through the heroic
leadership.
Uh,
many people who lived in this community,
uh,
my office is just a few blocks from the church were Dr. King pastored in 1955.
We are just a few blocks from the corner of Rosa Parks.
Refused to give up her seat.
And around me are the landmarks where activism by people who were black and
white,
young and old force this country to recognize,
uh,
that the legalized use of racial bias and discrimination,
the legal lies,
marginalization and subordination of people of color could no longer be
tolerated.
It's interesting,
uh,
to be celebrating the 50th anniversary of many of these milestone achievements
and civil rights and then be required to read McCleskey vs camp because the
McClusky decision that actually stands in stark opposition to much of what was
discussed and achieved,
uh,
in the 1960s accord in the class game does something that I've never really
recovered from,
which is to kind of talk about and to concede bias and discrimination and
America's death penalty.
And,
uh,
I think one of the challenging things when you read McCluskey is to see the
court painfully aware of these disparities.
I mean,
this one's a case that was presented to the court after a long line of cases had
asked the court to deal more honestly and more effectively with the legacy of
racial bias and the middle justice system.
When you look at death penalty cases,
you actually have to see this trilogy emerge.
It begins with Greg in 19,
excuse me,
with Fermin in 1972,
but the court strikes down the death penalty after declaring that it's
arbitrary,
it's capricious.
It's like being struck by lightning.
And the park affirming that I'm interested in is actually the part where Justice
Marshall Educate the court about its history of racial bias and discrimination.
And it's Justice Marshall that points out that between 1930 and the time of the
Furman decision in 1970 to 87% of the people who executed for the crime of were
African Americans,
uh,
convicted of crimes involving white victims that almost all of the people that's
cute.
It for that offense where people executed for offenses involving victims who are
white and his racial legacy.
This racially discriminatory context is what's really meant by the arbitrariness
language,
the capriciousness language that the court uses in striking down the death
penalty and affirming.
Now and then of course we have the grant decision in 1976 it's a few years
later,
uh,
reinstating capital punishment,
upholding capital's punishment and lawyers from the legal defense fund made the
argument that um,
nothing had changed in America or too little had changed in America now to
justify the court finding the death penalty constitutional now in ways that it
had not four years earlier.
But the corpus in a different mood.
And the court essentially said,
well,
we're not going to presume that the modern death penalty wool,
I act in the same discriminatory manner that the old Desmond t act,
they credited these new guided discretion statutes and these new procedures as
safeguards that would shield the death penalty fuck the racialized
discriminatory history,
uh,
that Ted sustained and created it.
And of course,
uh,
those of us who are working on these cases quickly recognize that these new
procedures,
these new safeguards were inadequate to overcome the legacy of racial bias and
discrimination.
Now that surrounds the criminal justice system.
And that gave rise to a death penalty that was every bit as biased and
discriminatory,
uh,
in the late 1980s.
And that's the context that,
uh,
set up the McCleskey decision.
It was a choice by litigators to prove to the court that the safeguards were not
working,
that the death penalty was still biased and discriminatory and the data was very
compelling.
Uh,
there was a study done.
The study presented some very,
uh,
shocking but powerful findings about the prevalence of race bias,
being 11 times more likely to get the death penalty if the victim is white than
that.
The victim was black,
was an astonishing finding.
The finding that you're 22 times more likely to get the death penalty if the
defendant is black and the victim is white.
It was an astonishing pining,
even the 4.3 times more likely to get the death penalty if the victim is white
than if the victim is black.
A statistic that the court relied on was an astonishing finding.
It's an incredible showing of the prevalence of race consciousness in a
Georgia's death penalty then to have the court except these data to make the
choice to not quibble with the data,
to believe what the day to say to us about disparities based on race and
nonetheless uphold Georgia's death penalty was,
I think the difficult thing.
Uh,
and I tell people all the time that in my career and I've been representing
people on death row now for nearly 30 years in my career,
probably nothing has been harder for me than reading.
Now the court's decision in the class ski,
we had allowed ourselves to be hopeful about what the court might do a and to
read a five,
four decision where the court talks about these disparities as if they are just
artifacts of our society.
They are just,
uh,
in the landscape in ways that we have to tolerate and embrace was deeply
distressing.
Uh,
the court had a line of reasoning that said,
well,
basically if we recognize the disparities in the death penalty and we create
constitutional remedies for these racial disparities in the death penalty,
it couldn't be just a matter of time before lawyers start complaining about the
same kinds of race disparities in the administration of other kinds of crimes
and criminal laws.
And they'll find the same disparities for drug crimes and property crimes and
other violent crimes.
And,
uh,
this,
this fear,
justice Brennan in his descent characterize it as a fear of too much justice,
uh,
cause the court to decide to do nothing.
And for many of us that was deeply disheartening,
but it was the second part of the court's opinion that I found most distressing
this line,
which where the court says a certain amount of bias,
a certain quantum of discrimination is in the court's opinion inevitable.
And that language is the language that still haunts me.
It still troubles me.
It's what really,
really has changed my relationship to the law,
uh,
because we cannot talk about the inevitability of race bias in a society like
America without doing deep injury,
uh,
to our efforts and confronting race bias.
I'm a product of Brown versus board of education or grew up in the community,
were black children,
could not go to school.
Uh,
in the public schools.
We had to go to a colored school.
And I remember when lawyers came into our community to implement the Brown
decision.
And,
but for their willingness to intervene,
but for their applying and implementing Brown in my community,
I wouldn't be sitting here talking to you today until I know the power of the
law.
I know the power of what the court can do,
not when it rejects evidence of race bias and discrimination.
And I know the consequences of that law when the court refuses to do that.
And I just want to offer a little bit of analysis of why I think the court got
it wrong.
I think the court got it wrong.
Um,
for the same reason that we often get it wrong,
we think and talk about racial inequality in America.
When we talk about racial injustice in America,
we tend not to talk in historical terms.
We have a very superficial understanding of what our legacy,
our history of racial inequality has done.
And it means that we sometimes react to claims of racial bias and discrimination
in a very superficial way and were easily provoked by the assertion that there
is racial bias where easily discouraged in thinking carefully and critically
about what these assertions me.
And we're quick to be exhausted by the whole topic.
And what's sad is that it doesn't take very much in most parts of this country
to create racial conflict,
racial tension.
You experience it probably as law students and certainly as college students,
you experience it when you go back into your communities.
Um,
there are oftentimes things that happen that create some discomfort around the
topic of race.
And I think that's in part because,
yeah,
we have not dealt with this issue,
uh,
in an in an appropriate historical way.
And so I think the court gets it wrong because they fail to appreciate the ways
in which the death penalty creates another institutional relationship to African
Americans and the people of color in this country.
That's part of a long line of relationships.
And it's only way you think about this institutional,
a relationship in an historical context that you get to a different place.
And for me becomes important to talk about these issues differently,
to contextualize them.
You can't understand the death penalty in America today and certainly claims of
racial bias in the depth domain America today without understanding slavery.
You know,
we've been interested in talking about slavery because slavery created myths
about African American people,
but that have not been adequately addressed.
Slavery in America wasn't like slavery in other parts of the world as some
transitional state,
some transitory status that you could fall into because of bad decisions or
being conquered in a war.
It wasn't like that in America.
Slavery in America was a racialized.
It was a,
a system that was created,
um,
afford labor for economic development that was focused on people who were black
people who are African descent.
And we created narratives to justify this about these people.
And we said they weren't really fully human,
that they had qualities and deficits and attributes that are required and
benefited from enslavement.
And we use this insane narrative to justify the morality of slavery and to even,
uh,
feel good about what we were doing.
And as a result of that,
uh,
we,
had a racialized system of slavery in this country that could not be,
ah,
eliminated by simply eliminating slavery.
The 13th amendment didn't talk about the myths,
uh,
created about black inferiority.
It didn't talk about all of the ways in which people of color had been a thought
of as less than human.
And neither of the emancipation proclamation nor the 13th amendment had the
power to overcome these myths.
And because we didn't talk about the miss,
we just tried to move on.
We didn't really end slavery.
We just created a new form of it.
Slavery didn't end.
It evolved.
And it created a second institution that you see that beginning at the end of
reconstruction carried on to a World War II,
uh,
that I define as terror.
It was the American terrorism.
It was the experience of racial terror that shaped the lives of people of color
from the end of reconstruction until World War II.
It was the experience of daily worrying about being lynched daily,
worrying about being arrested and released as a conflict,
a daily worried with threats of violence and intimidation from,
uh,
the law enforcement or any person who was white could say anything at any moment
that could cost you your life.
And it's for these reasons that we have the segregated south,
that we still have a today.
People organize themselves on the other side of the railroad tracks for security
from the terror and the violence and the lynchings and that sense of threat and
injury,
which was so dominant in the deep south,
uh,
was absolutely overwhelming in shaping a race relations in this country.
Of course,
then the third institution becomes a apartheid Jim Crow laws,
uh,
role in a legitimating racial hierarchy and racial subordination the way we
enacted codes and conventions and statutes and provisions,
uh,
to insist on these divided lines,
defined by race.
And again,
our efforts of confronting that Wa were noble and historic and revolutionary,
but they were also in complete,
uh,
because we didn't actually talk about all the damage that had been done by
decades of segregation and humiliation.
When I was a child,
my parents wouldn't take me into town with them because they didn't want me to
see them humiliated by any white person who chose to say something insulting to
them.
He chose to say something or unfair to them.
And that sense of injury,
that sense of trauma has not been addressed.
We didn't do a what other countries have done to overcome decades of human
rights abuses.
We didn't commit ourselves to a process of truth and reconciliation.
And because of that,
we have not reconciled herself to this history in South Africa.
There was a recognition that after apartheid there had to be truth and
reconciliation.
In Rwanda,
there's a recognition that after the genocide,
there must be a truth and reconciliation in this country.
There was a need after the civil rights demonstrations in the 1960s after the
assassination of Dr. King,
uh,
four process of truth and reconciliation.
But we didn't do it.
And because we didn't do it,
a fourth institution emerge and it is the institution of mass incarceration and
the crown on that institution is the death penalty because it combined all of
these historical antecedents,
the myths about a dangerousness of people of color and the threat that they
pose.
It's the reason why these disparities documented by David Ball goes in the
class,
game exist.
They would not exist in the country without our history of slavery.
They would not exist in a country without our history of terror and lynching.
They would not exist without decades of segregation and racial subordination.
And the court doesn't talk about that because they don't talk about it.
They minimize the significance of tolerating and tolerating.
It of course,
makes this institution like the other institutions and institutions that will
persist and prevail until there is some consciousness that says this is not
consistent with a just society with a fair society,
but an equal society.
And so for me,
uh,
the court's decision in the class fee is like the court's decision in Plessy,
like the court's decision in dred Scott.
It is a concession to conventional norms and values that tolerate systemized
structural racism and bigotry in ways for which there is no justification and
light these other decisions.
It will be a decision that at some point we'll be seen as a low point in the
court's jurisprudence.
You cannot talk about the inevitability of bias and discrimination in the nation
as fractured and,
and destroyed by racial oppression as ours.
You cannot talk about,
uh,
the acceptibility of these attributes and features of the death penalty when you
reflect on the legacy of lynching.
I gave some lectures in Germany talking about the correlation between racial
bias and the death penalty in America.
And when I finished that was struck by how the German scholars,
uh,
stood up and all said,
well,
we can't have the death penalty in Germany.
And they were quite adamant that there could never be a moment in Germany's
future where they could accept putting people in gas chambers and executing
them.
And they said,
it doesn't matter whether the people we execute are guilty of heinous crimes.
They said,
we cannot do that.
our history of the Holocaust means we can never again engage in systematic.
Kevin.
And I thought about that on my flight back home.
I thought,
well,
yes,
it would be very,
very difficult for me to stay silent in a world where people were still being
putting gas chambers in Germany.
I,
the very notion of it provokes me to the point where I know I'd have to say
something.
Oh,
the flight back and started thinking,
well,
what would I feel like if I were living at a time where the nation state of
Germany was still executing people and the people they were disproportionately
executing were Jewish.
And the more I reflect on that,
the more I realized I couldn't be silent in such a world.
I'd have to do something.
I'd have to say something,
I'd have to go there and have to fight it.
And then I got off the plane in Alabama and I walked to my car and drove to my
office were buried in the ground,
or the bodies of thousands of people were the victims of lynching and slavery
and racial violence and racial terror and increasingly the death penalty.
And it's in that context that the court's decision that McCluskey and could have
been very different if the court recognize the history of racial inequality in
America.
They've thought about slavery.
If they thought about lynching,
if they thought about segregation,
then they would have realized that the question presented in the classic,
he is not a question about whether people convicted of crimes deserve to die for
their offenses.
They would recognize the question presented by McCluskey is,
do we deserve to kill?
And when we have systems of justice that tolerate racial bias,
when we have decision makers who would disproportionately white,
and we allow people of color to be excluded from juries,
and we allow our conscious and unconscious racial bias to create the kinds of
results documented about professor baldness in those researchers.
And it's through that Lens that you recognized the inherent,
uh,
illogic of the McCleskey outcome.
And more than that,
the chain full character of the McClusky opinion.
And as you've probably heard,
just as a pow and he retired,
uh,
gave voice to his deep regret about McClaskey wished he could change his vote,
but re recreating a time when the court can revisit this issue and it can take a
different approach.
Can think more honestly about our history.
We'll take some doing.
And that's,
I think the challenge of McCleskey.
Uh,
Steve Professor Bride has probably told you that it was a very disheartening
moment for those of us representing people on death row limit.
Classic came down in 1987,
but after that moment passed,
we began to reflect on what the court actually said.
And what the court actually said is that you didn't prove that the individual
decision makers and we're acting with race anamis that you didn't show us that
there was real bias behind some of these outcomes and that actually created an
opportunity to rethink the way we litigate.
And that's when we started working on cases.
Steve did the in Georgia and others did around the south where we tried to
expose,
uh,
the history of racial bias that had situated many of the capital prosecutions
that we saw that and we continue to see today.
And so whether a system is fully just completely free of racial bias becomes a
threshold question.
Uh,
when you think about the death penalty and if that system is not free of racial
bias,
if that threshold requirement has not been met,
then there is an obligation,
I believe,
to give voice to a racial discrimination,
conscious and unconscious racial thinking.
Uh,
disparate outcomes,
racialized talking,
racialized thinking,
racialized prosecutions,
racialized sentencings all have to be exposed because in the absence of that
exposure,
we contribute to the institution.
It's like being silent during slavery.
It's like being silent during,
it's like being silent during segregation.
I think the [inaudible] is demanding from us either silence or activism.
And it's one of the reasons why it's such an important case regardless of
whether you choose to go into criminal defense work or criminal justice work.
It is an important case and I think it requires us to say something.
Uh,
and you'll hear a lot more about that from Steve and you'll certainly see that
in the kind of career that he is created.
But I think of this case and I think of this area of the law as a critically
important area because it says something not only about the port and about what
law could do,
but it says something about us and whether we will choose to be the kind of
people who stand with others just sitting and the kind of people who have speak,
but others are quiet.
The kind of people who are rallying against the institution of slavery that
Fight Against Lynching,
uh,
that fight against segregation and that fight against,
tolerated,
uh,
acculturated racialize use of the death penalty.
And that's exciting part of the work that you're doing of the course that you're
taking.
Uh,
and I look forward to hearing more about it.
I look forward to meeting some of you,
uh,
when you finish your time at Yale or when I get to Yale and I'm delighted to
have a opportunity to share a few thoughts about this case and about the legacy
that it represents.
A wish I could be there with you.
Again,
I'm sorry for my congested state,
but I hope you all the best
and your continued studies.
Thanks.